en el aeropuerto de kiev decenas de
expatriados se preparan para regresar a
sus casas distintos países han llamado a
sus ciudadanos residentes en ucrania a
abandonar rápidamente el país sportzone
nación no logro creer que vaya a
estallar una guerra espero que lo
evitemos
el 90% de los marroquíes que conozco que
estudian en ucrania ya tomaron un vuelo
hacia marruecos bala por otro lado las
autoridades ucranianas piden no ceder al
pánico y a pesar de las recomendaciones
de sus países de origen hay quienes
deciden quedarse en su casa en kiev
la mayoría de personas que conozco que
llevan aquí mucho tiempo han elegido
quedarse convivimos con la guerra desde
hace 8 años cuando desde el extranjero
la gente de acumulación de tropas en la
frontera piensa que representan una gran
amenaza pero en realidad los combates no
han cesado desde 2014
tampoco ha llegado la hora de partida
para el presidente de la cámara de
comercio franco ucraniana
la comunidad francesa sobre todo la
comunidad de negocios elige más bien
y espera una evolución concreta de la
situación
el elíseo no pide a sus expatriados que
regresen a francia pero recomienda
evitar las zonas fronterizas con rusia